大家好 欢迎回到 FP101x 函数式程序设计
今天要学的是 Haskell 的简单入门
我最喜欢的电影之一是
龙威小子 如果你没看过这部电影
现在把视频停下来 先去看电影
每当我需要学习新东西时 我都重看一遍 龙威小子
我可以告诉你 我看过 20 到 30 遍 每一次我看的时候 我都会学到一些新的东西
如果你看了这部电影 你就知道
这边的男孩 丹尼尔 想要学习空手道
而这位宫城先生却让他做了许多
丹尼尔认为没有意义的练习 他十分不耐烦
但为了学新东西 必须进行许多练习 因为这涉及到肌肉记忆
或者对应到编程中 手指记忆
那些是不需要特殊考虑的事情
需要反复训练的 一次又一次地重复
这就是我们今天的课程中要做的事情
所以别像丹尼尔一样不耐烦
像一个大人一样 把该做的练习做了
一遍 又一遍 一遍 又一遍
直到它完全成为下意识行为
这样你的脑力才能用来解决真正的问题
不用再考虑基础问题了 每次学习新东西时
你都可以重新看这部优秀的电影
让我们看一点 Haskell 吧 这门课程中使用的
Haskell 实现是 Glasgow Haskell Compiler
有时也被称为荣耀的（Glorious） Haskell 编译器
GHC 是一个领先的 Haskell 实现
它既有编译器 又有交互式的
REPL 循环（Read Evaluate Print Loop）供你输入代码
GHC解释器的这种交互式的特性 让用 Haskell 进行试验十分容易
因此对这门课也很有用
许多练习都可以使用 GHC 来完成
我不认为这是作弊
作为程序员 我们的确应该用编译器来帮助我们
计算机是用来帮助我们编程的
如果我们非要不用 那就太蠢了
GHC 可以从这个网站中免费获得 这个链接
也同样会放在课程网站上 你也可以
谷歌或者必应搜索 Haskell platform
这一实现在主流平台比如 Mac Windows 和 Linux 上 都可以使用 要启动 GHC
只需要从命令行输入 ghci 命令
之后你可以看到 一些文字提示和一个提示符
Prelude> 你可以在这里打字输入表达式了
比如我们可以输入表达式 2 + 3 * 4
GHCi 就会打印对应的结果 此时我们其实是
将 GHCi 当成计算器来用
有点像命令行界面的计算器
而不是用按钮输入的计算器 我们在这里可以看到
2 + 3 * 4 的值显然是 14
因此乘法的优先级比加法更高
大部分语言中都是这样的
也没什么好奇怪的
如果我们想先进行加法 再进行乘法
就需要加上括号 因此改写成 (2 + 3) * 4
结果是 20 我们可以
对更复杂表达式求值 比如 (3 ^ 2 + 4 ^ 2) 的平方根
结果是 5
你可以看到这里的 Prelude> 提示符
Haskell 的 Prelude 好比 Java 的 JDK 包括了许多标准函数
内置在 Haskell 中的 在网站上
将展示获得其他 Haskell 库的方法
但现在先不要引入过多细节
你可以读一下那些 但现在
我们专注于标准的库函数 也就是标准的 Prelude
Prelude 中的很多函数
都是关于列表（List）的函数
我们将举几个例子 之后的课程中
会用几种不同的方式实现这些函数
第一个函数是 head 接收一个列表作为输入
在 Haskell 中 列表的表示方式是用方括号
元素用逗号分开
因此 [1,2,3,4,5] 的 head 就是
不出意外地是 1 而 tail
和 head 相对 取列表中除了第一个元素（head）以外的所有元素
因此 [1,2,3,4,5] 的 tail 就是
列表 [2,3,4,5]
我们也可以选中列表的第 n 个元素
使用双叹号操作符 如果想选中第二个元素
从列表 [1,2,3,4,5] 中 就可以得到
3 这告诉我们什么呢
列表的第一个元素下标是 0
Haskell 从 0 开始算数组的下标
这里使用两个叹号作为标志 这么做是有道理的 因为在 Haskell 中
列表不是数组 所以用下标访问列表
比如取列表中下标为 2 的元素
会遍历整个列表 因此我们遍历列表 去掉 1
再去掉 2 最终返回 3 完成操作所需要的时间并不是常数
用下标访问列表 和用下标访问数组不同
在 Haskell 中所需时间和下标数呈线性关系
更一般地 和列表的长度呈线性关系
幸运的是 很少在实际中用到这个操作符
如果想用下标访问数组
就说明自己没有做足够的练习
仍然还在使用那套过程式程序设计的思维
也就是使用数组的思维
在 Haskell 中 我们通常使用高阶函数 比如 map filter fold 而非下标
在列表上进行复杂操作 看下一个例子
take 3 取出列表的前三个元素
如果我们传入列表 [1,2,3,4,5]
它就返回前三个元素
[1,2,3] 而 drop 与之相反 它接受一个数字
和一个列表 然后去掉列表的前三个元素
某种程度上 drop 和 take 是
head 和 tail 的推广 head 和 tail
只取列表的第一个元素和其余的元素 而 take 和 drop 可以推广到任意个数
计算列表的长度 可以调用 length 函数 [1,2,3,4,5] 的长度是 5
这里需要再提一下 Haskell 中的列表和其他语言中的数组不同
因此计算长度不是一个常数时间的操作
花费的时间和列表的长度呈线性关系
sum 计算所有元素的和 如果将 [1,2,3,4,5] 传入 sum
结果就是 15 product
和 sum 类似 但不是加起来 而是乘起来
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 的乘积 和 5 的阶乘一样
是 120 另一个常用的操作是连接两个列表
拿两个列表 把它们合成一个新的列表
比如在 [1,2,3] 后面接上 [4,5]
就得到了列表 [1,2,3,4,5] 这里的最后一个函数是取列表的倒序
reverse [1,2,3,4,5] 得到
[5,4,3,2,1] 之后的课程中
我们将用多种方式自己定义这些函数
现在可以试试它们能干什么
然后就可以准备好实现它们
因为我们就会知道它们应该做什么了
这是一张很重要的幻灯片
是关于函数调用的
Haskell 和数学十分不同
同时也和其他的编程语言不同
在数学中 当我们应用一个函数时
也就是你在学校中学分析时所用的数学中
当将一个函数应用到一个参数上时
总使用括号 在这里 我们应用一个函数
即 f 应用到参数 a 和 b 上 然后加上 c 空格 d 在数学中
一般遵从物理的记号
也就是空格的意思是乘法
如果你在一本数学教材中
看到 c d 这样的写法
通常意味着 c 乘以 d
因此应用一个函数时 需要使用
括号来消除歧义 因为在 Haskell 中
函数调用远比乘法更常用
而在物理中
乘法更常用 因此将空白记号分配给乘法
也就是看不到的记号
最 空 的记号 而在 Haskell 中
函数调用用空白符号来表示
因此符号才不至于太多
所以在 Haskell 中 不写 f (a,b) + c d
函数调用使用空格表示 因此写成 f a b + c * d
在多数编程语言中要写 f (a, b) 某种程度上
这是两种最差的写法的结合 需要把一切都显式地写出来
Haskell 决定函数调用拿空格来表示 乘法用乘号来表示
此外 函数调用优先级更高
比任何其他操作符都高 如果看到
f a + b 含义就是 f 应用到 a 上
结果再加上 b 而不是将 f
应用到 (a + b) 的结果上
大家需要适应一下这种写法 它的意思不是
f 乘以 a 再加上 b 而是
f 应用到 a 上 再加上 b 好比乘法比加法的优先级高
这张表格给出了 一些表达式
这边是 Haskell 的写法
另一边是数学的写法 这些写法是你应该忘记的
让我把它挡起来 这你是你应该忘记的东西
这边是你应该学习的东西
所以忘了我身后这边的写法 学习另一边的写法
不是写 f 括号 x 而是写
f 空格 x 不写 f 传入两个参数
而是写 f 应用到 x 上 再把结果应用到 y 上
不是写 f 括号 g 括号 x 而是写
f 应用到 g 在 x 上应用的结果 后面我们可以看到
我们可以用复合函数的方法写成
f 复合到 g 上
其他的例子应该很显然
如果你只看它们的形状 别去解释它们 你就能发现
这边的 Haskell 代码比那边的更加简洁
Haskell 程序员都很懒 不想打太多字
因此这样看起来漂亮很多
这也是 Haskell 语法这样设计的原因
十分感谢 第 1 部分到此结束了
让我们在第 1 章剩下的部分再见吧